[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
PROFESSOR: Welcome back to 8.20.
In this section and
the following ones,
we talk about paradoxes
in special relativity.
A paradox is something which is
absurd or self-contradictory.
So we have statements
which don't really make
any sense when put together.
The pole in the barn paradox
is rather interesting.
And we will analyze this, and
at the end of the discussion,
we hopefully agree that
there is no paradox here.
It's a pseudo paradox.
So the situation is as follows.
We have Alice.
She has a pole.
The pole is 10 meters long
in her reference frame.
And Bob is very proud
of his New England
barn which is, in his
reference frame, 8 meters long.
Alice, however, is moving
with a velocity of 0.6 times
the speed of light, which gives
us a gamma factor of 1.25.
Does the pole fit into the
barn is the question, or not?
So stop here and think
about this for a second,
and we will continue
with an analysis of this.
So here is the analysis
for Alice's frame
and the analysis
for Bob's frame.
For Alice, the barn
in her reference frame
is Lorentz contracted.
It's 6.4 meters long, but
her pole is 10 meters long.
So we should clearly
answer this question
by saying it doesn't fit.
In Bob's frame, the
barn is 8 meters long,
and the pole is
Lorentz contracted--
also 8 meters long.
So Bob will say, yeah, it
fits-- it just barely fits.
They're exactly the same
size, so yes, it all
fits into the barn.
And here is where
you might think
this is an absurd statement.
They cannot be both right.
We will see they can.
They can both be right.
They just disagreed on
the fact that events
happen simultaneously.
What are the
crucial events here?
When does the barn
hit the end-- does
the pole hit the
end of the barn,
and when does the back of the
pole hit the front of the barn?
Those are the two things
we have to study in detail.
But let's get to it.
How can they, or why
can they disagree?
So the idea is that you
draw space-time diagrams
for the pole in
the barn, and show
that there's no paradox by using
the world lines of the pole.
Before we do this, we're going
to analyze this a little bit
more.
So assume that the front of the
pole enters the barn at time
equals 0 for both Bob and Alice.
Then Bob observes the
pole entering his barn,
and it takes 44.4 nanoseconds--
8 meters divided by 0.6
times the speed of light--
for the front of the pole to
reach the back of the barn,
and the back of the pole to
reach the front of the barn.
So after 44 nanoseconds,
in Bob's reference frame,
the pole is in the barn.
Alice, however, sees the
barn Lorentz contracted.
It's 6.4 meters long.
She moves this 0.6 times
the speed of light.
So for her, she reaches the
back after 35.6 nanoseconds,
in which case, Bob's
clock only shows
28.4 nanoseconds,
because Alice's clock
time is Lorentz contracted.
So we can clearly conclude
here that that's not
enough time for Bob such that
the pole actually entered
the barn for the full length.
So the back of the
pole is still outside.
So we want to consider
three different events.
The first event is
after 44 nanoseconds,
and in the space of 8 meters
in Bob's reference frame.
For Alice-- this is the
situation we just analyzed--
36.6-- 35.6 nanoseconds passed.
And in her reference frame,
the front of the pole
is at 0 meters.
The second event is
then the other side
of the barn in Bob's
reference frame
after 44.4 nanoseconds 0 meters.
He sees-- or she sees that
55 nanoseconds have passed.
We use Lorentz
transformation here,
but the position
is minus 10 meters.
And the last point is 28.49
nanoseconds and 0 meters.
That is the observation
when Alice sees the end
of the-- front of the barn--
the front of the pole
at the end of the barn.
That translates
into Alice's frame
a 35.6 nanoseconds,
and minus 6.4 meters.
So the minus 6.4 meters
tells you very clearly
what we just already said.
The back of the pole
is still outside.
So that's the quantitative or
numerical kind of evaluation.
And we can also show
the very same thing
in the space-time diagram.
So we show the
space-time diagram here,
and this is Bob's
reference frame.
So the pole just touched
the front of his barn,
and the barn is
located at 8 meters--
the end of the barn
is located 8 meters.
The front of the barn
is located at 0 meters.
After 44 nanoseconds, there's
event number one and event
number two.
The pole is fully in the barn.
But we can also show the
pole in event number three.
So one-- where is
the end of the pole?
We look at this diagram here.
Where is the end of the pole
when the front of the pole
hits the end of the barn?
You see clearly there's
a piece sticking out.
We saw that there's--
in this event here,
6.6 meters in Alice's
frame still seeking out.
So we see that event number
three is located here,
and not all of the pole is
actually contained within the.
So Bob and Alice disagree
on whether the front
and the back of the pole are
in the barn simultaneously.
That's where the situation
becomes contradictory.
They don't agree that two events
which happened at the same time
in their reference frame--
in Bob's reference frame
occurs at the same time
in Alice's reference.